foreign
no one really ever loves false alarms
especially when you're the first
responder so today we'll cover how to
troubleshoot unexpected incidents
created by your Cloud monitoring
alerting policies
Google Cloud monitoring allows you to
create an alert policy on metric or log
base data alert policies can be
configured to have one or several
conditions
to troubleshoot misfied alerts it's
important to understand a few key fields
that Define when and how a metric based
alert should be triggered
the alignment period or the rolling
window defines a look-back interval from
a particular point in time
the rolling window function dictates how
the points are aggregated
condition type defines how the alert
should be triggered that is when a
particular metric violates a threshold
or when a metric data is missing for a
certain period
the retest window is the amount of time
an alert policy condition is violated
before an incident is created
we will also go over how missing data
can affect your alert policies in a
later example
to learn more about creating monitoring
alerts refer to the video linked here
let's go over a specific scenario where
a false alert is triggered you configure
an alert policy using a custom metric to
monitor a process's thread count after a
day you get your first incident
notification surprisingly you notice
that the value of the metric never went
above the threshold on the chart why did
we get a false alert there can be
multiple causes such as alertness
configuration and ingestion delays let's
take a look at the configuration in more
detail
firstly the rolling window and retest
window for this alert are configured at
two minutes the condition type is
defined to trigger an incident when the
custom metric goes above the threshold
of 100. if the condition continues to be
violated for two minutes an incident
will get created
one explanation of why a false alert was
triggered is that the policy
configuration does not account for
metric delays it's likely that at this
point in time condition evaluation
became true since there was a value
above the threshold of a hundred then
due to metric delays no value was
ingested for at least two minutes
resulting in the condition evaluation to
remain true for the entire retest window
causing the alert to trigger
once the delayed metric data is ingested
due to interpolation the value does not
appear on the chart and it looks like
the condition was never violated
let's confirm if this custom metric has
any delays navigate to metrics Explorer
and zoom into the last few minutes
here you can see there is no data
received within the past three minutes
there you go this clearly indicates that
an incident was caused due to ingestion
delays to prevent ingestion delays
resulting in unexpected incidents is
recommended to increase the rolling
window to at least three times the
sampling rate you can find the sampling
rate for any platform metric in the
description of the video now let's take
a look at another scenario let's say you
create a log base metric and set up an
alert policy to notify you when the
number of Acts of user sessions on your
IES site goes above 250. you set the
rolling window to two minutes and the
retest window to 5 minutes the alert
seems to be working as expected and
after about a week you receive an
unexpected incident notification
when you look at the incident chart the
metric data never reached the threshold
meaning that the condition was never
violated
why would an incident be created when
the number of active user sessions never
exceeded 250. let's go over to logs
Explorer to review the actual logs
we can see that the receive timestamps
for the sum of these logs are about 6
minutes after the actual time stamp this
means that there was a delay in log
ingestion at the time of the incident
going back to alert policy configuration
we can see that missing data results in
violation of the condition meaning that
since there's no data the condition is
evaluated to be true
to prevent false alerts like this it's a
good idea to configure the evaluation of
missing data fields accordingly in this
case it makes sense to set the
evaluation of missing data to not be
treated as a violation of the condition
it's also good to keep in mind that log
base metrics can be delayed and
backfilled for up to 10 minutes
so we would also want to increase the
rolling window to at least 10 minutes to
account for delays
these are just a couple of examples of
wire alert policies may be misfiring
in summary when configuring your alert
policy carefully select your rolling and
re-test windows depending on your
preferred alerting Behavior
these windows should consider potential
metric and log injection delays lastly
Define how you would like the missing
data to be interpreted depending on the
frequency and reliability of the metric
data and your specific use case
for more information check out these
documentation links thanks for watching
foreign
[Music]